i've been making game of thrones videos
for four years across two channels and
it just so happens that this is my 100th
game of thrones video so it's
essentially fate to be ranking the 10
best episodes for this ranking i'll be
evaluating every scene within an episode
to determine its placements and am
looking for consistency between scene
quality like he may hold the winds of
winter as one of the best episodes in
the show given that it has the great
sept explosion and a couple of other
standout scenes but personally i think
there's some bad scenes that weighed the
episode down along with some logical
issues that i explored my last game of
thrones video with that aside let's get
into the rankings
number 10 the wolf and the lion
the perfect way to start the list with a
classic breastplate stretcher line it's
so refreshing going back and watching a
comedic scene like this after looking
through so much of the cock-infested
plague of comedy that is the later
seasons but here you actually have
playful banter between then making fun
of his best friends and robert wailing
on his squire for fun the jokes are way
more creative and mark addie who plays
robert has so much infectious charisma
that makes this scene a joy to watch
then this leads into the jousting
tournament that features called gain
bull seeing these two titans go at it is
entrancing and it's also so badass how
clogged game both respects robert by
kneeling for him when call to while
simultaneously dodging the mountain's
attack the sudden mountain clan ambush
on tyrion is cool and abrupt and it's
crazy how tyrion killed someone with a
shield it's also very heroic that
despite being a captive tyrion decides
to make the decision of helping catelyn
rather than escaping we have another
meme with bran a common saying but not
their official motto theon and ross is
seen as is alright arya is chasing after
her lunch and we get a big turning point
of varus revealing to ned that robert
baratheon is going to be killed i love
the subtle camera technique of pushing
on each character's face breaking the
traditional static shot to convey the
message that something jurassic just
happened this scene significantly cranks
up the conspiracy intrigue and now the
stakes are so much higher in king's
landing now that we have this
information it's also really neat detail
seeing varys and ilerio discussing their
plan about wanting to destabilize
westeros to make it an easier target for
daenerys then this is followed by varus
and littlefinger the battle of wits is
so unique and there's an active shifting
power dynamic during their conversation
as they reveal information about each
other that the other doesn't think they
know
i could listen to these two characters
monologue at each other for hours we get
the classic impregnate line from brawn
and another great small council
discussion that is infused with the
ethics of killing a baby to save the
future of the kingdom which sparks a
heated argument that shows each
character's perspective doubling as
character development and plot
development we meet crazy on lysa and
tyrion is thrown into a sky cell i've
always loved the aesthetic of sky cells
that's actually what initially turned me
on to the show as a fun fact sir loris
and renly have a steamy scene and
initially i didn't care much for it but
this line makes me love it so much more
targaryen girl will die every time he
talks about killing her i swear the
table rises six inches it's a shame you
can't muster the same enthusiasm for his
wife robert and cersei have a long
conversation and this is in my top 25
moments for the show i can go on for a
while about it but there's so much
fascinating background exposed between
these two characters and it's so tragic
how cersei did love robert but robert's
lust towards lyanna ruined it after this
the episode ends with a climactic action
scene between jaime and ned so we have
the battle of wits and the battle of
swords an overall great start on this
list
number nine
the lion and the rose
this episode is primarily here obviously
because of the purple wedding sequence
that takes up about half of the episode
but the rest of the scenes that came
before it syringe from good to okay we
are reintroduced to ramsay in a haunting
and dark scene of hunting an innocent
girl through the woods the fact that
he's hunting her for the sole fact that
she made miranda jealous is insane
tyrion and jamie have a quick scene
that's alright and i especially love
this funny and witty line try the ball
cersei can't get enough of it since one
killed robert
however the scene does come across as
slightly underwhelming because this is
the first time they meet since season
one and they don't really talk about
much besides jaime's lost hand we have
the start of braun and jaime's iconic
duo and the banter between them feels so
organic i still have my right hand plan
on growing it back
beyond shaming ramsay's face while he
tells him that robstark is dead has a
surprising amount of tension and is a
creative way to showcase theon's loyalty
to ramsay the wedding gift-giving is
fine and joffrey destroying tyrion's
gift with his sword was a definite
highlight tyrion breaking shay's heart
is honestly really hard to watch given
how much tyrion has shafted shae it's
like he has been slowly peeling off a
band-aid since season 3 and this was the
final poll
branding bran his scenes are never
really that amazing nor are they
terrible and they are generally just
middle of the road quality for the last
scene before the purple wedding there's
a dinner with melisandre stannis and
solis and this is the one part of the
episode i'd find myself skipping there's
not a lot of interesting backstory and
the whole conversation is imbued with
awkward mom energy but at least we get
more serene and finally the purple
wedding this sequence is chocked full of
so many small details and moments
between numerous characters that it
never feels boring at any moment
small things like mace getting wrecked
by elena podrick checking out the ladies
elena yonking the poison off a sansa's
necklace jaime big [ __ ] loris cersei
sussing brienne oberyn and tywin trading
insults with smiles cersei being
maniacal varus getting bonked this scene
has everything there's so much depth and
complexities happening within the space
that it makes it feel so real and all
those praises aren't even including the
bombastic finale of joffrey's death
easily one of the best in the show and
every character involved gives their
best in terms of acting
number eight and now his watch has ended
i wasn't expecting this episode to be on
the list but after reviewing it it has a
lot of great scenes it opens with jaime
essentially hitting rock bottom as he
scrolls around in the mud while he gets
a pride beat out of him this shot of
jaime traumatized with his severed hand
on his neck is so grotesque and it
heavily contrasts season 1 jaime i even
treasure the moment after this where
bran calls out jaime for being a coward
for giving up so easily tyrion and varys
have another dialogue scene and unlike
others we actually get concrete
backstory for varys since it's so rare
that we get any it makes a few scenes in
which we learn about it that much more
engaging and alluring it also shows the
dark side of varys and it's a shame that
this is really the most evil varus gets
in the show and he just becomes a good
guy in comparison to the books
and of course we get this banger of a
line too
influence grows like a weed
i tended mine patiently where i managed
to wrap them around something
very special
bran gets heated off a tree ross and
varys talk about podrick's long rod and
we get a nice and wholesome scene
between cersei and elena talking about
how much they love their children having
this personal moment is a cool change of
pace for cersei given that she's
normally fighting almost everyone she's
in a scene with then in the intellectual
pairing of elena and cersei is always
fun to watch ramsay bamboozles theon and
when theon spills the beans we get a
very intimate moment with him and how it
was an utter mistake by betraying his
true family funny contrast that we go
from that to immediately getting
tortured tywin talks to cersei and any
taiwan scene is basically ester
political entry gets spiked with a fun
pairing between varys and elena their
playful banter between each other shows
their sharp wits and seeing these two
veterans scheme together is legendary
sansa finally gets some hope in her life
the mutiny at crosser's keep is insane
and the irony of giara mormont dying in
the most unhonorable way is delicious
the hound roasting the brotherhood never
gets old and something big finally
happens in daenerys's storyline
throughout season 2 she's mostly had a
lackluster journey through qarth but now
that she's actually acquiring power in a
badass way it makes your plotline
infinitely more entertaining ironically
i think this is her most triumphant
moment in her overall story given her
victories are a tad bit underwhelming
and we finally get the conqueror we've
been waiting for
number 7
baylor
similar to the line in the rose this
episode is primarily here for the
execution of ned stark i do like this
episode a bit more because there are two
amazing precursor scenes one of them
being jon's talk with maester aemon in
which he's revealed he's actually a
targaryen it makes the advice he gives
jon have a lot of validity given the
amount of personal conflict eamon went
through when his family got wiped out by
robert's rebellion but he couldn't do
anything because he was swarmed to the
night's watch and we get the love is the
death of duty amen targaryen is a
literal goat and he steals so many
scenes he's in
the other scene that i thoroughly enjoy
is tyrion shay and braun bonding over
tyrion's game of guessing their past
that's actually a brilliant way to
disguise character background exposition
as natural dialogue by making it a fun
game while also adding in the fact that
turin makes assumptions on character
types the twist that shay goes against
every trait that tyrion assumes of her
makes her so much more interesting while
turing simultaneously gets rolled by her
i'd love these chill scenes where
characters go on about their past like
tyrion talking about taisha and screwed
up things taiwan has done to him some
other noteworthy moments are the debate
between importance of honor versus
survival with varys and ned showing how
slimy and weird walder frey is jon
getting longclaw and celebrating with
the boys sir jorah defeating a dothraki
bloodrider in single combat and robstark
winning his first battle the one hiccup
in this episode is the cop-out of not
showing the battle but it's definitely
understandable from a budget's
standpoint and the fact that it wasn't
entirely essential to the plots it's
just annoying that they built up to it
so much and didn't give it proper payoff
then you know there's one other small
scene left where the main character dies
nothing big or anything the
ramifications of this single event set
the entire show into a blazing path of
riveting storytelling this moment is
single-handedly one of the best twists
in cinema given how expertly it plays
against the expectations of our main
hero surviving every major obstacle we
are even led to believe for the last two
episodes that no harm will come to ned
but by going against that notion it
makes the twist even more shocking and
the execution of the scene is extremely
visceral the sound drowning out so we
only hear ned's breathing gives the
moment a haunting layer of surrealism as
we see our favorite character lose his
head
number six
you win or you die
god damn what an ending the culmination
of all the political intrigue brewing
into a twisting hurricane of knives and
backstabs in which littlefinger betrays
ned was perfect that iconic image of
littlefinger holding a knife to ned's
throat is burned into my mind as to what
game of thrones is all about we even
have more top 25 moments within this
episode given that we have the
introductory scene with tywin what a
badass man i love how it isn't even
required for him to be scanning a deer
but he just is it shows off how
resourceful he is how he isn't afraid of
getting his hands dirty and it
foreshadows him defeating the baratheons
giving his gutting their sigil the
efficiency of storytelling here is
astounding because we both learned so
much about taiwan while also learning
nuggets of wisdom tied to the lannister
psyche and this also isn't just a time
when introduction but it establishes his
relationship with jaime and how much
value he places in his children
keeping the fire hot after the start of
the episode this leads into ned
confronting cersei about her having kids
with jaime i love how she doesn't even
deny it here and instead goes into a
monologue about why she made all those
choices it allows us to actually
sympathize with a villain for once along
with having some killer dialogue
littlefinger coaches some horrors from
the sidelines and this may not seem like
an important scene but we actually
learned some motivation for
littlefinger's character theon harasses
osha but gets rolled and smoked by
maester lewin i thought she was our
prisoner are the two mutually exclusive
in your experience
robert baratheon dies rests his
beautiful and sexy soul even on his
deathbed robert has more charisma than
most of the characters in season 8. the
man is a living legend he's over here
coughing up blood while making funny
jokes give us a robert's rebellion spin
off you cowards
sergiora ejects an imposter in a tense
scene and the boys become men
ned stark attempts playing the political
game with littlefinger and renly and
it's fun re-watching this scene because
since ned is honorable by refusing to
back anyone but stannis the one true
king he ends up alienating any of his
potential allies
then finally we have kal droga being the
coolest human being in the galaxy i
adore how much jason momoa is slaying in
this role he's having the time of his
life
number five
fire and blood
to me this is the quintessential game of
thrones episode it's very well rounded
in the sense that we get excellent
scheming betrayal heartbreak and
triumphs amongst these riveting plot
lines i love the ending and how the
writers perfectly align each of the main
subplots in which they hit a similar
thematic beat of heading into the
unknown of characters starting their own
personal journeys i love seeing the
death of ned stark ripple throughout
westeros and seeing each character deal
with their own sorrow i love the vile
turn of joffrey fully embracing his
demon side and becoming a fully
blossomed villain i love the irony of
the strongest warrior dying to an
infection which shatters our
expectations i love varys and
littlefinger talking about their epic
aspirations every scene is basically
perfect even this small scene with
maester pai still talking about past
scenes is engrossing as hell and meme
worthy too if this episode had a little
bit more groundbreaking sauce in it then
it'd easily be within my top 3 but i
can't really fault the episode that much
given that ned stark died the episode
prior
number 4 kissed by fire
exploding onto the scene with a trial by
combat for the hound this episode
immediately grabs your attention and
excitement the fight is adrenaline
feeling each character is bashing
through the environment obliterating
shields and the hound cuts through
barrack's sword and the twist of berry
coming back to life elevates the scene
even higher by opening up a whole new
magical avenue of resurrections
jon snow gets to the finish line with
egret and is essentially at his happiest
ruse bolton has a maniacal cute little
moment with jaime where he delays
telling him whether or not cersei got
killed during the blackwater elena mops
the floor with tyrion in their first
dialogue scene together and it just
makes me love her to death the fact that
she shows up and dances around one of
the wittiest characters makes her a
legend easily one of the best characters
next to tywin arya has a tragic moment
with gendry where he makes the decision
to stay with the brotherhood she's come
to essentially love him and is the last
person she has left in terms of inner
family then she has a conversation with
barrick and thoros and we should learn
more about resurrections also this line
from arya is depressing
could you bring back a man without a
head not six times
just once the downfall rob stark worsens
through his trail of deteriorating
decisions and this episode has arguably
one of the best dialogue scenes in the
show in which we get a monologue from
jaime talking about how he had to kill
the mad king to save king's landing
jaime shows away his exterior armored
shell and our outlook of jaime evolves
into a more heroic night i also love how
this revelation blowers align of which
oaths you should follow and the acting
here oh
chef's kiss
this is the equivalent of tyrion's trial
scene but for jaime after that
masterpiece we then get one of the most
heartwarming scenes with davos and
shireen hanging out in the dungeon as
she teaches him how to read that
beautiful look he gives her makes my
heart flutter
greyworm establishes he respects and is
devoted to daenerys in an uplifting
scene that can promise her army isn't
just a drone of mindless killers
littlefinger is still oozing wisdom as
always and the episode ends in an
explosive family conversation between
cersei tyrion and tywin the fact that he
demolishes his own children makes him
even more of a savage tyrion and cersei
have essentially had impunity for the
last couple of seasons and are finally
put into place by this absolute sigma
chad
number three
the reigns of castamere
yeah you know why this episode is here
the red wedding is easily the best scene
in game of thrones due to how shocking
and brutal the twist was george the mad
lad martin got away with killing two
main characters
the whole aura of this scene exudes a
feeling that something feels off due to
the fact that it's so elongated there's
also a lot of signs leading up to the
betrayal that rewards viewers who really
pay attention like ruse refusing to
drink wine the phrase casually locking
the doors and the musicians playing the
reigns of castamere
god just the execution is perfect
from the acting the brute force change
in pace and the grotesque violence that
shatters our feelings and makes us
shower tears for the characters we loved
and now the question is does the rest of
the episode have the consistency they
call the overall package outstanding the
answer is a definite yes robstark making
a mental walder fury has a lot of
tension and we are curious about whether
or not he is holding a grudge which he
kind of drop that suspicion once they
commit to marrying edmure tully and then
they kill everyone any scene with the
hound in arya is pog and in this episode
there's two of them bran works into
hodar for the first time to stop him
from shouting which is cool and jon snow
finally changes sides when he's asked to
kill an innocent man the action here
feels a bit unrealistic though given
that jon has to fight a 1v3 or 4 against
the wildlings it falls into the action
trope of fighting one person at a time
to mask the fact that it's impossible to
fight a group at once and to get around
that they cut to torment wrestling egret
and also cut over to bran the direwolves
do help but that isn't until later on
and this is only a very small issue the
battle for yonkai does a much better job
at showcasing fighting a group of
enemies given that grey worm sergiora
and daario are all back to back all in
all though the reigns of cassamir is
basically filled in with good scenes
while having a perfect final sequence
number two
black water
now we're getting to the episodes that
are a complete banger through and
through the battle sequence is the main
draw here but even the dialogue scenes
leading up to the battle are amazing we
have great conversations like davos
contrasting mathos blind loyalty and
cockiness with his pragmatic view of the
difficulty of cracking king's landing
varus telling tyrion about how much he
hates magic and we have bronze funny
humor i saw you kill a man with a shield
you'll be unstoppable with an axe then
for scenes that aren't driven by
dialogue like braun and the hound
standoff they are so engaging because of
how much they raise attention in an
already stressful environment
george rr martin does a magnificent job
of stacking up conflict to make the
upcoming obstacle of sanus seem even
more daunting like everyone being scared
fighting between soldiers joffrey
abandoning everyone and people dropping
equipment that's why it's so relieving
and cathartic when tyrion explodes the
blackwater with wildfire and visually
this is the first time in the show where
you're actually awestruck the show's
ambition of massive battles is a reality
now and this explosion drastically
raises your hype for the upcoming attack
for the cinematography and action it's
all coherent and you can actually see
what's happening on screen unlike in
season 8 but for the blackwater we have
a perfect mix of wide shots to give us a
bearing of space and medium shots to
quickly cut between people fighting not
only is this battle destroy action but
there's a lot of character moments like
the hound getting traumatized by fire
and stamping at the king and tyrion's
epic speech and speaking of tyrion this
is basically his peak and i love how
happy he feels when everyone is cheering
his name after leading a successful
counter-attack one of the main reasons
why i wouldn't put this as number one is
that i think cersei's drunken dialogue
scenes grind the pace to a halt during
the battle it makes you want to skip
over them despite those scenes not
actually being bad it's cool seeing a
drunken cersei essentially letting loose
about how much she hates everything and
everyone lana heady seems like she's
having a great time in the role and
maybe they should have cut one of the
three cersei scenes but it's alright and
obviously the ending is great because it
has tywin saving the day no bias here
number one
the watchers on the wall
i think this is both one of the most
rewatchable episodes along with each and
every scene being a 9 to a 10 out of 10.
this overall episode is very similar to
blackwater but to me i like the bigger
scale of the battle the higher budget
led some more dynamic cinematography
like long takes tracking all around
castle black more grand vfx and more
ambitious action another difference is
that we have character duels like
tormund versus her alicer and jon vs
stir
it shakes up the action conflict of just
mowing down extras which can become
repetitive after a while and instead
gives us a personal 1v1 of two opposing
characters of similar skill leading to
an engaging fight and i also love how
there's so many cool moments stitched
throughout the battle like a giant
riding a mammoth dropping a scythe on
people climbing the wall a giant
shooting an arrow and impaling someone
and the boys coming together in harmony
as they chant their vows to breed
courage in the face of a charging giant
this battle is flat out perfection and
even the dialogue scenes before it don't
let up the awkward talk of john telling
sam about love is cute amon talking
about past love is pure joy that gives
us a beautiful moment of intimacy where
living in past memories can suppress the
oncoming doom and sir alistar giving jon
great advice about second guessing
yourself as a leader can be detrimental
and john actually uses that advice later
on in season seven and eight every
character has a moment to shine in this
episode and it feels perfectly balanced
jon finally gets his much deserved role
of leadership and he feels like a
complete badass once he enters the fight
sam also becomes a man and he channels
his chad energy for once by choosing to
protect the boys over hanging out with
gilly and finally the ending the death
of egret is heartbreaking and i adore
how jon is able to have a warm final
moment with her while we are swept away
by the gorgeous cinematography the
watchers on the wall easily deserves my
top spot
thank you guys for watching and for the
next ranking in the future i'll most
likely do the top 10 worst game of
thrones episodes let me know in the
comments what your top 10 would be